homies what is good lefco here and this
week the left go show is brought to you
by the walmart fan shop the ultimate
source for all sports fans shop
officially licensed sports merchandise
like this fire right here from all 32
nfl teams including top brands like nike
fanatics and majestic and options for
every budget visit the fan shop at
walmart.com
bleacher report
[Music]
hey week three is in the book some
people are excited some people are upset
i'm just happy to be with brian
westbrook in studio i'm wearing the same
shirt as last week yeah you know why
tell me why because i'm never going to
abandon this team but more importantly
walmart i mentioned it they're going to
be sponsoring all the shows this week i
got some fresh gear i curated some i
literally went in there man and i was
like these are some good eagle stuff oh
texans fans are like this ooh patriots
fans will like this yeah and i asked
walmart walmart.com bleacher report i
need this one shirt for me personally
and they sent it to me yeah
christian okay ooh the nigerian
nightmare old school right there i i
like old school i mean i love knight i
gave you a brian westbrook shirt no i
was keeping this one yeah you gave me a
small shirt i gave it to my wife it was
for your child oh my wife could wear it
she's hers now it's her yeah that's what
happens i took my son to a game
yesterday actually i took all the kids
to a game which i'm just i have three
kids so i'm yes just letting you know
six two sounds like you really might pay
attention to that yeah it was it was not
a ideal situation but my son how old is
he he's two okay i mean he's sitting
paying atten the only time that he
listened to me all day long was when i
was like just watch the game he's
sitting on a high chair watching the
game really rooting throwing popcorn
like a crazy philadelphia eagles fan i
was proud of him did you see the
philadelphia fan um that was interviewed
and he was catching babe he was yes the
fire it was a fire and he goes he goes
we were catching babies unlike nelson
aguilar good hands but here's the deal i
might be wearing this shirt we may have
just talked about it we're not talking
about the eagles yeah look uh some of
you guys have dm me and been like look i
don't want this to be an eagles podcast
we'll talk about them when they [ __ ]
deserve it they don't deserve it no so
you know what we're gonna talk about the
[ __ ] giants
danny [ __ ] dimes
daniel jones
comes out goes down 28 to 10
and then turns into
one of the most incredible second halfs
i've seen
it was the largest comeback for giant
history in 49 years brian westbrook yeah
that defense and he comes out there
my favorite story is that in the second
quarter right before he ran for a
touchdown he went into the huddle and he
looks at everybody he goes let's [ __ ]
score yeah and no one on the team had
heard him curse before and they all went
what the hell and he goes and gets the
touchdown
and it made me realize that i curse so
much that i will never have a moment in
my life never happened
like it makes me want to not curse for
the next month yeah so that in one
podcast with you i go hey westbrook i
[ __ ] agree with you and you're like
whoa
but i'll never have that you sent me a
text message like that a couple weeks
ago yeah like let's look let's just go
let's do it and that got me going but
yeah you tell that i curse too much it
cuts a little bit too much but 18 points
down a comeback for daniel jones
that offense looked totally different
most importantly
that offense didn't have their mvp
saquon so he's out four to six weeks
high ankle spraying this down together
the question obviously for daniel jones
is can you do it without him repeatedly
but to come back from 18 down uh you
picked a good team to play against them
yes tabitha is just not very good
defensively but he showed a couple
things and this is important for young
quarterbacks we see it with lamar we
don't see it as much of kyler we think
he has this ability but he has the
ability to affect the game obviously arm
talent of course but being able to move
around in the pocket being able to run a
little bit that changes a bunch of
things daniel jones showed me yesterday
because you always wonder when you hear
about runners
does their speed translate to the nfl
kyler he finally started running
yesterday it's evident lamarr i mean he
broke so many ankles in kansas city it's
evident
daniel jones ability to beat a member of
the buck secondary to the outside and
score that's right not even the one
where he ran up right up the middle but
what did uh there were so many times
where eli would have gone down at just
being touched by that i wouldn't have
ran ever that's the difference eli you
know there are plays listen this
offensive line still was bad right nate
soldier allowed four sacks to shaquille
barrett on the outside shaquille barrett
now he shocked barry with getting after
it he's been getting after it all season
so that that i mean you kind of
understand but i go how many sacks would
he have had if eli was in maybe six
twice as many maybe seven well eli as
soon as he sensed pressure he crumbled
at least jones is like listen i'm gonna
scramble i'm gonna use my legs i'm gonna
extend the play that changes your
offensive line and here's the other
thing we talked about it last week just
a bit when you have guys that come in
there
it provides instant credibility they saw
what he did in the preseason they're
saying you know what we might not have
been able to win with eli we can
actually win with this guy yeah he can
take us to the next level so everybody
rises up a little bit more 18 points
come back that's that's impressive for a
rookie quarterback
it's weird to say this is an eagles fan
i watched the game yesterday with a
giants fan dense dead who works here at
bleacher report
to watch the joy
before the game the excitement of going
we have a new era to watch the joy in
game of him making throws to sterling
shepherd and evan ingram and going this
is a quarterback to build a round to see
the defense where ximenez is getting
sacks at big times and a rookie
linebacker in connelly getting an
interception in the fourth quarter to
watch him go this giants fan
that if the bucks make this field goal
it's okay don't worry because we're
gonna build it made me oddly enough as
an eagles fan go
i am really happy for giants fans right
now because what they've gone through
the last three years has has been very
painful they've been forced to watch the
decline of somebody that they've adored
for two decades
and i if a guy gave me two super bowls i
would defend them but eventually it
weighs on you
i am i am legitimately and i can't
believe i'm saying this happy for giants
fans because
it's it's completely different i look at
the giant season it's completely turned
around do i believe that he's going to
win every game absolutely not they still
went into a 28 to 10 hole because that
defense is still abysmal and that
offensive line is trash but the future
of the giants is bright and danny dimes
is dishing them out there's two things
that you like as a just an analyst as
you watch the games two things that you
want every team every every coach says
this how do you start games and how do
you start the second half first two
possessions they get ten points that
just builds your confidence you're
talking about the offense that was
stagnant couldn't move
with with eli yes and you lose your best
player
you get 10 points on the board first two
possessions that's that's going to be
huge then you start the second half two
first two possession touchdown touchdown
that's how you win football games that's
how you instill confidence and of course
their last drive they score a touchdown
these are things these are building
blocks i mean you talk about daniel
jones listen he had a lot of success in
the preseason you never know if it's
going to trigger no you never know if
it's going to be the third teamers
absolutely now you get into the regular
season as pat sherman when you watch him
in this press conference he's saying
we know he could do it he's he's excited
now because the offense that he had
between with eli was this big he
couldn't do but small things with eli
certain things he just didn't want to do
he didn't have the leg the arm talent as
well as the leg talent
with daniel jones you're kind of like
andy reed with patrick mahomes
everything in my offense is wide open i
could do anything that i wanted to do
and he can throw the ball he can make it
work the guys around to believe in him
is huge
75-yard touchdown to evan ingram 46-yard
pass to darius slayton 36-yard pass to
sterling shepherd 26-yard pass to
sterling shepherd 21 yard pass to darius
slayton
those are five plays of 20 yards or more
those are explosive plays changes things
i don't think eli makes any of those i
haven't seen explosive plays from the
giants other than saquon since o'dell
was on this team eli wasn't willing
daniel jones gives it back eli doesn't
throw the ball down the field that's not
his thing he doesn't want to take
chances he doesn't want to throw the
ball down the field daniel jones makes
them a defense played the entire field
we talk about it with the speed
receivers they open the field up you
have a bunch of guys that can run on
this team sterling shepard can run
however if he doesn't get the ball the
defense doesn't respect it at least
daniel jones is going to throw the ball
deep and give his guys a chance he makes
the defense play totally different they
have to play the entire width and depth
of the football field this is like a
totally different football team and the
good thing for them next sunday one
o'clock they get the washington redskins
coming to new york that's huge huge a
defense that hasn't been very good they
don't defend the ball the past very well
this is a great another great
opportunity to provide confidence in
this young quarterback jameis winston
and mike evans clearly connecting early
yes 190 yards three touchdowns they
focused on janoris jenkins they took
advantage he's getting beat up all over
the place here is my issue with bruce
arians everyone right now is saying i
can't believe he took the delay of game
and all that and he came out and said it
was on purpose reporters are coming out
right now and saying they can kick a
longer field goal because apparently it
was better yeah sure here's my issue
with the tampa bay bucks what i want to
say
the defense for the tampa bay bucks
has looked pretty darn good overall we
see what the niners are doing they had a
pick six on jimmy garoppolo and really
stymied them second week they kind of
shut down cam newton and what they were
doing the first half was great and they
fell off a cliff i think the buccaneers
still have really good pieces but here's
my issue
in the first quarter your field goal
kicker misses an extra point in the
first quarter your field goal kicker has
an extra point blocked you throw it down
to guess who chris godwin to get down to
the nine yard line you snap the ball at
34 seconds
you waited to spike it until 13. yeah
try to win the game
if i have a kicker who's already missed
an extra point which is around the same
distance don't give him a time i've
already had a field goal blocked and i
have mike evans who literally is one of
like the four receivers in football that
i could put it in a place where truly
only he could get it and he's having
maybe the best game of his career i
don't care about delay games i don't
care about field goals put it in the
corner of the end zone and see if you
can win it
what like what like i
win the game why would you ever play for
a tie why would you ever play for a
situation where if you can win with a
touchdown do that this is the time it
doesn't make any sense this is the same
franchise that has been at nightmares
for the last five years with field goal
kickers where they drafted one in the
second round and they can't find one so
after this game where you've let an
18-point game lead slip away let's rely
on his leg you're crazy why yeah why
would you do that i think you you know
for a veteran coach because it's easy to
blame a kicker well that's that can't be
the reason you i mean you want to get
closer and closer and closer and you're
saying oh this is automatic but
really is it he's already missed today
he already has missed
so
there's nothing automatic for him i
don't want to put the fate of my team
that's battled back and you put up some
points to in the kicker's land
i'm the coach i want to put it in the
guys i trust mike evans i trust him yes
i'll give him an opportunity
go get him a jump off in today's climate
where we're at in the nfl a jump ball is
a penalty
that's a catch yeah it can be anything
anything gets you a much much closer
terrible coaching job by bruce erin and
i'm surprised because i think he's a
pretty good coach yeah but he's also
somebody that goes i know exactly what
i'm doing
um
barkley to me in a in a weird way
daniel jones took the sacrifice of
saquon like we had to sacrifice saquon
to the football gods but all we wanted
to see was those two play together yes
that's what we talked about last night
we got like a quarter of it yeah we
didn't see enough
i was asking myself the question
is it better
for daniel jones now that saquon is hurt
i mean he's gonna be without him for
four to six weeks and i've had a high
ankle sprain and they take a long time
what is what is it about a high ankle
sprain that takes so long well it's your
ligaments they get weakened so they get
stretched out some of them get torn in
and it's almost it's almost better to
have a broken ankle because you're
breaking the bone you've heard this so
many times yes but what like what does
it feel like
well it feels like you can't you can't
support yourself okay you literally your
ankle is something that you need
especially at the running back position
you want to make a cut to the right or
left you need your ankle and did you get
one in the middle of the season yeah and
so how long did it take you to it takes
almost all season because you're using
it every weekend it'll feel good on
wednesday it'll hurt all day on thursday
it'll feel good on friday so now you're
talking about how do you get better
every single week how do you get better
every single day because you can't
practice like that and so now you go
into the game you may feel great in the
grand the game but now monday and
tuesday wednesday you're hurt for the
next week and so it's about your rehab
it's about getting back there next week
it's just hard to do it and saquon is
one of these guys he's a bigger guy big
legs he's strong but he likes to make a
lot of cuts he's going to need his
ankles
at some point in this season
i just hope that he comes back
four weeks later and saying hey i'm
healthy completely healthy it's just
hard to do with a high ankle sprain i i
you know what i say rest him
our big concern about saquon barkley
right was by the time this team is ready
to be a contender he'd be hit out
giants fans you won the first game what
a coronation for daniel jones it's
beautiful guess what if saquon's
supposed to be out four let him sit
eight
what are we fighting for you're not
gonna get past the cowboys there are too
many teams in the nfc fighting for a
wild card spot
let's rest saquon double
and let him save hits this season that
we can go longer with him and daniel
jones we do not need to rush him back
well here's the problem the problem with
that is yeah that might have worked
against the buccaneers and that may work
against the redskins next week
the question is is that going to work
against the better teams lebron west
without a running game without the best
player on your team giants finish this
season
five and 11 with sequels absolutely but
four and 12 without them yeah who
[ __ ] cares no it's not about who
cares it's about supporting your young
quarterbacks putting weapons around your
young queer it's not about how many
games you're going to win they're still
not going to be this is about 500 this
is how i'd like to support daniel jones
if one guy has four sacks against nate
solder put a [ __ ] tight end on that
side they should absolutely what that's
that's a no-brainer have have a running
back chip him how about nate soldier
steps up and block someone how about
that how about you say hey nate uh just
do that one job that one thing that we
brought you here from you would you do
that you have young kids you saw a
little mermaid yes
ursula steals the voice of ariel so that
she can go above ground what happens is
when you play for the patriots dante
scarnecki looks better sucks out all he
goes he goes i'm gonna give you
incredible pro bowl left tackle skills
but when you leave he'll have nothing
and that's what happened to nature well
i'll tell you what putting a tight end
over there having to run it back
something i mean i remember we played
games where you know we had guys reserve
guys playing and i was like hey i'm just
going to chip don don't even think about
throwing me to football i'm gonna help
you be able to throw to someone else
because if i don't then guess what
you're gonna get sacked yes you have to
do a better job of helping guys and so
yeah if you were like me you were going
crazy at the end of giant's bucks why
because the giants covered the plus six
and a half plus there you go and you
know what i want to give a special shout
out to the third member of this i would
i think we should all sit around and do
one show together warren sharp i just
i'm getting hit up by so many of you
right now the saints first half hit
against the seattle seahawks i'm gonna
be giving you picks from now on i need
that uh rams browns first half under
lions plus seven warren went 5-0 last
week what we've what we're creating here
is special
westbrook on mondays and wednesdays is
giving you that unfiltered [ __ ]
goodness yeah warren sharp is giving you
that mustache wearing nerdism that we
all love i need some of that in my life
i need i need some of that i was 2-1
this week on my three picks i was
surprised because before that the last
two weeks i was one in five i was
terrible i'm currently in the super
contest which is you have to pick five
games against the spread every week
which is insane i'm currently 10 and
five it's not bad i am in the top 33
percent of the contest right now not bad
oh hey let's not click let's not do the
clicking thing anymore well that was 33
you like that i did um but
we're we're [ __ ] riding high right
now yeah feeling good other thing i want
to say coming out wednesday night the
next episode of ditch the playbook
and we have it with the ultimate
internet king quinn williams quinton
williams he's the bless you thank you
yes he is the funniest dude ever
i'm going to give the listeners of 33
what is going to be we are trying to
make quinn williams the king of the
internet taking the best memes of the
internet and turning them into queens
and so what i'm asking the 33
is when it comes out on wednesday you
share the f out of it he's already
pretty good i mean he's amazing he's
amazing and i'm telling you
he was a joy to be around we are
adopting him into the 33
we are going to get him in here one day
for a podcast but when you see the
episode retweet best episode you've ever
seen trust me um the other rookie
quarterback that
daniel jones was the sixth pick in the
draft yes and everybody doubted
there well there was one rookie
quarterback that was a sixth round pick
and everybody doubted him but now
everybody loves them yeah gardner
minshew yeah did you get a chance to
watch him on thursday are you aboard the
garden minshew train you know what it
was a couple weeks ago you were like no
you got to get on the train i was like
nope not getting annoyed i don't believe
it
yeah my thing is is i'm not the guy
going he's so cool you should like him
because he's cool i'm going i think he's
a gamer yeah like i don't care about all
the other stuff i think he is a gamer i
think he can take this team to the next
level obviously they have a decent run
game with fournette but he's a guy that
can whip it can make all the throws and
the thing that i love about young
quarterbacks especially with a little
swagger the confidence is through the
roof the confidence is probably twice as
high as their ability they believe that
they can make any throw and they walk
around and talk it and and the guys in
the locker room whether it's true or not
the guy's in that offensive line the
same way that daniel jones went into the
huddle and said what he said it changes
the thought inside of you offensive line
i'm gonna block a little bit longer i'm
gonna run my route you know what this
guy can give me the ball i'm gonna run a
little bit more crisp route i'm gonna do
a little bit more that's the confidence
that mensure has really instilled into
that offense and and it's amazing
because there are some questions there's
a bunch of questions on that offensive
side of the board for the jaguars but
the ability to go out there and beat a
titan's team and and i think mike brabel
is a i think he's actually a pretty good
coach i think that he brings a nasty
disciplined football team yes but to
beat them the sound way that they did i
think that was impressive it was they it
was
not only that garter minshew looked
immensely better than marcus mariota way
better i watched mason rudolph and the
steelers were saying we're comfortable
trading for minka fitzpatrick because we
believe we can build around mason
rudolph and we're not going to need that
draft pick so many people doubted that
just letting you know mason rudolph did
not look good nope i would rather have
gardner minshew than mason rudolph
now i want to give a shout out to jaylen
ramsey who played and then came out and
said i got the flu oh i don't think i
can play this weekend oh my goodness i
mean that's that's great you know what
i'm not going to be able to make it in
sorry i'm not going to be able to make
it i'm going to play next week because i
feel sick a week ahead of time i'm going
to feel sick all week long so don't even
bother sending medicines don't come past
the house i'm sick
don't don't call me yes
[ __ ] great that's
better than that but i wanted to ask you
i'm sick
who do you think has had the better
like
start to their career movie wise daniel
jones or gardner minshew
ah that's a good one the reason you
can't tell yet is because you haven't
seen the movie trailer okay and that's
what we're gonna make right now let's do
that so i have a script for you you have
not seen this yet i have not uh this is
what we're gonna do first
uh so kind of read over your lines all
right
get ready for them
and uh and i want everyone out there
who has had the better movie start thus
far daniel jones or gardner minshew but
you need to know who their characters
are so the first thing we're gonna do is
we're gonna give you the movie trailer
for danny dimes all right let's do it
a franchise in need of a legend
eli just doesn't have any more and it's
killing me a city in need of a hero we
need a hero but who millions of years
ago a prophecy foretold that if eli
doesn't have it anymore a new
quarterback who was an exact replica but
with better foot speed and more charisma
would rise
who is that
this fall
one small step for the front office one
giant leap for the giants
broadway jones
rated r for excessively sexy shots of
quarterback sneaks up the middle
daniel jones is broadway jones
okay so that's daniel jones i felt good
about that you did a great job i felt
good i was i was hype have you anchored
have you acted before no of course not
played football i act all the time all
right so daniel jones broadway jones
coming out of nowhere thousands of years
in the making foretold through
hieroglyphics on the walls of a pyramid
but now
the movie trailer for gardner minshew
gardner minshew was just a regular kid
from mississippi who dreamed of playing
in the nfl
quit playing that dang football in the
house son you stink until one day
whoa what is this hair on my face he
grew a mustache
i don't know who this kid is but he just
broke every school record that's one
heck of a mustache this summer
everyone's invited on the mustache ride
gardner minshew is stache mountain rated
pg-13
stash mountain
dude i love your acting skills listen
that those short good scripts that's
short those shorts that minshew had on
good quads he had good quads
if you're into that they're not saquon
they're not saquon no listen but if you
don't start being okay
are you okay with that yes a little much
a little much for me a little leg a
little bit too much leg a little too
much hair on the legs i have such a lot
going on for a long time if i had abs i
wouldn't wear a shirt really yes you
would be the jogger with no shirt on yes
if i was jacked i wouldn't wear sleeves
really and if i had quads that were
similar to saquons you wouldn't i'm
wearing that european cut short that's
me bro i don't have it though so i wear
this
you wear i wear this i cover up every
cover up everything okay okay i just i
mean i i once had a six-pack i once had
nice quads not to say quan's length no
to where he's at but yeah i don't need
to show everybody i'm kind of like ah
you'll see you can see it through the
clothes i don't need to show you i will
say it is interesting that cam dresses
funny and we critique him yes gardner
minshew dresses funny and we celebrate
him he reminds me of koi detmer
that that's when i see him i'm saying
that's koi yes he had the mascot dressed
like him i think was pretty cool or was
he interesting he was the starter yes
like that's what's so interesting yes
all right so who do you think has the
better movie beginning gardner minshew
coming in because of an injury uh to the
starter you know and he's stretching in
a jock strap and he's out there kind of
well let's figure this out boys yeah or
daniel jones replacing a legend going
down 18 driving him back with a curse
word i i love to come back i love
comeback stories i love the fact that
people are saying hey you're down you'll
never be able to do it but also you're
following the guy that won two super
bowls you're without your best weapon
just come back and do your thing i love
a comeback story i also can understand
the menshu side of things that hey it's
just me playing football in the backyard
she's kind of kind of reminiscent as a
brett favre type of thing it's just me
slinging the ball around getting guys
involved i can see both sides of it to
me
comeback story is always going to win
gotcha come backstory my um my thing is
is i love i think their personalities
fit the city is perfect new york needs a
quarterback like daniel jones that's not
going to talk a lot so one thing eli did
great didn't really alienate anybody and
jacksonville needed a quarterback that
didn't give a [ __ ]
because that's their defense that's
right one thing i'm going to say is i
heard something this morning that uh
westbrook you'll learn this about me i'm
not afraid to talk about other
commentators
because let's get over ourselves we're
all adult and if you want to have a take
nobody really went out there and said
they believed in daniel jones no and i'm
watching get up and i'm hearing rex ryan
they're going rex you were one of the
few guys that said daniel jones can make
him what did you see that no one else
saw
and this is what he said he said
honestly i had some inside information
number one
i heard that he can remember everything
and i went okay that's interesting
number two i heard that he broke his
right hand in an aau basketball
tournament and he won the tournament
with his left
the third thing i heard is that he
played on jay billis's basketball team
with two nba players and nobody hustled
harder yeah and i went are you [ __ ]
kidding me yeah yeah doesn't translate
to football rex ryan this is your
opportunity to i don't know make [ __ ] up
and say that you had scouts say that his
accuracy was incredible you could have
said that he had an injury which he did
in the most important part of his
development in sophomore and junior year
and thus we haven't been able to see the
best of who he is until now you can say
anything yeah
you're the king of the mountain you're
the only guy in the media that didn't
bash the draft pick and you're going to
come out with aau basketball tournaments
and hustling on jay bellas's team right
you told me that rex ryan said this and
you thought it was going to be something
different did he get a mark sanchez
tattooed on him he did jersey yeah well
yeah come on coaches don't do that i
just i mean i'm surprised i'm actually
surprised at you why i'm surprised it's
your surprise that rex said that it's
more of i see the opportunity in our
media space like i
am all over the ravens yes and i feel
vindicated to you and i am going to
pound that constantly speaking of which
you do owe me a dollar whoa whoa whoa
whoa you owe me a money what are you
talking about i don't owe you a money
you owe me a money meaning one money i
owe you a dollar for what because the
raven is lost
we bet that the ravens would cover the
seven he lost by five oh my goodness you
told me that you didn't want to do the
spread that we were just going to go
winners and losers we literally i can
literally play yeah bring it up it
literally says plus seven
we agreed on that yes
and then if jalen ramsey gets traded to
the lions you're gonna owe me another
dollar yes okay you lost that bet you
came in here thinking you won that bet i
thought i won that bet i was i told you
before the show i had something to tell
you and that was it i want my money yeah
no you owe me a dollar
this is why you need me and warren sharp
to help you he's betting that's exactly
what it is um but you know i'll tell you
this let's get into the game i am
oh okay i'm pleasantly surprised
because
i thought that this game was going to be
lopsided in kansas city's wedding
started to look it did start that way i
thought that kansas city you know you
score in the first four out of the five
first drives just to start the game 23
points in the second quarter just like
last week there's no way that the ravens
would be able to keep up with my my my
exact comment to you last week was that
this offense puts pressure on the
opposing defense of course but the
opposing offense just to keep up lamar
didn't have the best game passing the
football but i tell you that running
game
that's something that you can build on
customers
oh my goodness i mean it's just i i
thought that mark ingram had some juice
left when he came over i
you just never know you never know
because you trade guys you get rid of
them you know having 103 yards 16
carries three touchdowns yeah that's
impressive that can win you that
division easily so would you say after
the first few weeks i kept asking are
the baltimore ravens a super bowl
contender where do you stand with it now
i still think they're good
let's stop here they didn't win the
doggone game of course that's that's
that's the the real test so they they
have to be able to win these games they
also got to make sure guys are healthy
andrews has to get healthy i think brown
looks he seems to be flipping around
just a bit he has to get healthy in in
the quarterback position he has to be
better and listen throwing the football
is a big part of it we saw him running
around we know he can do that he has to
be better we're talking about them
competing on the super bowl levels right
against better competition the first
couple weeks average competition at best
most would say obviously they were
terrible but he has to get better i saw
something on this team to me they took a
next level jump they they kansas city is
at the top of the league right but
they're not they're not as far away as
some people thought including myself so
i came away from this game going
the ravens are gonna be the three seed
in the afc okay i can see that i believe
they are clearly the third best team in
the afc i believe they're competing with
indy i believe they're competing with uh
houston and buffalo but i think they're
better than all of those i agree with
that i also want to say this they have
an injury right now that i think um
people need to realize jimmy smith
hasn't played the last few huge injuries
and as sharp was saying on on friday's
show the splits of that defense with and
without jimmy smith are crazy
warren has been focusing that when you
play three or more wide receivers
against baltimore you get torn up
but i want to say
that i don't know if the ravens
impressed me or if they didn't they
impressed me because they had so many
mistakes in this game that if it goes
the other way who knows
they failed three two-point conversions
they stopped mahomes on third down then
they get a horse collar tackle on that
play which leads to a touchdown
gus edwards blasted off a 50-yard run
holding brought it back that's right
they had an interception in the red zone
there was a past interference away from
the play got called back they had an
interception on the homes that went
through the guy's hands and then sammy
watkins caught it and continued
now i do not want to say that everything
went their way because lamar jackson
also had like two miracles yes he had
two fourth and five plays one where he
threw it across the field and willie
snead had one of the most incredible
catches to keep the drive and then they
had another one where they threw it down
to the one and no cameras were there to
cover the offensive pass interference
but what i saw was
an offense that number one did not
abandon the run down by double digits in
the second half
they had a drive in the beginning of the
second half where it was ingram and
edwards and it was 10 yard runs easy
easy
lamar jackson also showed me that he's a
gamer
and that even though they lost the game
lamar was pulling magic and there are
only a few guys in this league that are
capable of making magic lamar mahomes
josh allen uh we haven't seen it
consistently from kyler but i think
kyler has that ability desean watson um
wentz has shown it over the years
obviously rogers but
lamar showed me that when push comes to
shove he's not just taking that sack on
fourth and long or third and long he can
make magic happen and i looked at
baltimore and i'm very concerned that
their inability to stop teams with three
wide receivers is going to continue but
i also believe that they played a very
special team and the one thing i'll say
is is i don't want to just focus on
baltimore because that's what i've done
we are witnessing in this era of the nfl
some of the most physically gifted
quarterbacks we've seen
josh allen has the bills at 3-0 and if
you watch that game guys it's his cannon
arm and it's his legs we watch desean
watson be the ultimate gamer and go into
the chargers and win that game his play
where he scrambles around and finds
takens is incredible we have lamar
jackson who's one of the fastest twitch
guys we've ever seen
and none of them hold a candle to
patrick mahomes that's right patrick
mahomes is far and away the best young
quarterback that anyone has seen
ridiculous and i do not want to hear it
anymore
patrick mahomes is hands down without a
doubt the most talented guy we've ever
seen at the quarterback position because
you can give me guys that are faster
mahomes is more accurate
you can give me guides that are more
accurate mahomes can hit 40 yards
further down the field there is nothing
this guy can't do and there is no moment
that he can't make patrick mahomes is
the most talented quarterback in the
history of the nfl and you cannot prove
me otherwise
i wouldn't that's how good i wouldn't be
mad with that statement patrick mahomes
has thrown for more than a thousand
yards brian westbrook in less than ten
quarters of football this season
he's had he had some of the best the the
best run of a young starting quarterback
that we've ever seen i mean we so we
understand that i think when you talk
about the combination of
the the the game plan that andy
possesses in front of him
he is the perfect person to be able to
to develop it to carry it out he's brett
favre x he has the ability to scramble
just like farm he has a little bit more
athletic ability stronger arm i mean
it's beautiful i love what they're doing
there he made some ridiculous throws
there obviously i love the way that andy
continues to use the screen game he
continues to do things that way but i
really want to talk about lamar just a
bit okay
you you mentioned something and really
my home says the same thing they make
plays outside of the offense at some
point the the coordinator said okay
we're gonna do five step drops you're
gonna throw the ball to this guy that's
gonna run a skinny post and he's gonna
throw it 30 to 30 yards down the field
and when you get in the game sometime a
defensive guy comes up to you you get
out of scramble you got to do different
things you got to make a play you got to
make a play outside of the offense both
of these guys jackson as well as mahomes
they have the ability to make plays that
not very many people in the league when
we're talking about pocket passers yes
obviously we mentioned eli early just
not willing to do it these there's not a
many people in the league that are
willing to make these plays not capable
yeah to making these plays and also
that's how you beat the patriots that's
exactly talk to any patriots fan their
biggest fear is playing a quarterback
that can move that's how they've lost
guys that can ab lib that can do stuff
out of the system and there are three
quarterbacks in the afc
that have a chance against the patriots
and in my mind and there's four excuse
me
lamar jackson
patrick mahomes
josh allen to sean watson through the
four co sean watson's hung up 34 on the
patriots patrick mahomes has hung up 35
on the patriots uh josh allen has had
some success against the patriots and
that defense is good and and and i think
that it that's what it takes and so
those are the guys that you can build
around because there are some guys that
when they're in the pocket that's all
they got and and i i that's lamar has
that gift well think about this when
you're a pocket passer you have to
especially as a young quarterback you
have to be so good to have an effect on
the team right when you talk about
daniel jones and lamar and mahomes they
you don't have to be as accurate because
you can make plays outside of the pocket
you don't have to be the best passer
period just from the pocket because you
have legs you have the ability to run to
make plays same thing you see kyle
island down there in uh in carolina they
have ability to make some plays with
their legs strong arms you're on time
one of the things that i was talking to
enberg just a little bit about this
before we're saying
we're a young quarterback
you know
you're you're starter and you have good
starters let's use uh uh cam for example
right cam good starter he makes plays
outside of the offense he really you
can't script it i mean when he's when
he's on he makes two years ago
he makes plays you you can't really
script it you don't really know what's
happening but but when you have a guy
come in like alan and says you know what
i'm going to run the offense the exact
way it's supposed to the offense just
looks more effective it looks like it
goes through you know it looks exactly
the way you plan it three-step drop ball
is out yeah things look smooth they look
fast things are working great these
young guys because they have the ability
and because the college game has changed
tremendously to more athletic guys
playing the position now these guys have
the ability to come in at an earlier
point in their career and make a big
time difference we saw with daniel jones
and i asked you last week i said does he
have the ability to run oh he didn't
really run that much in the preseason i
don't know if he can we saw him run a
little bit in college but he has uh he
has got wheels he has the ability to run
that changes things because defensively
you can never account for the
quarterback that can run we saw lamar
jackson all last year you can't account
for it that's a big help for a young
quarterback i um i think the other thing
about my homes that i liked i don't know
if everyone saw this end of the first
half they have a little bit of time left
and they're kind of in field goal range
and they show holmes and andy reid
yelling like my home's yelling at andy
reed on the sidelines yeah mahomes is
going i got 19 seconds left i've hung up
like 20 plus points in the second
quarter
why are you putting the kicker out there
let me take a shot give me a chance and
andy reached like kind of was like
smiling to calm him down but the thing i
like about mahomes is that he doesn't
turn off this isn't one of these young
guys that's happy with where he's
reached
he's obsessed with putting the game out
of reach and i respect john harbaugh in
this game going we're going to go for
two the entire game because that's what
it takes to play the chiefs part of the
chief's defense is your offense knowing
you have to score a touchdown every
possession and mahomes wanted to keep
pouring it on and i like that andy larry
loves that type of guy
he loves it i want to make a mention
here and of course i don't know that
lamar had his best game but
it was bad weather i mean it was it was
bad weather lamar's still having some
issue on some deep shots that's where
his accuracy is not there but he still
played well he still played well still
played well he's still developing though
i mean this is we're not we're not
seeing his best they're his best games
don't forget mahomes is technically your
three yeah because mahomes had a year of
sitting there and practicing with the
scout team and all that and it'll be
good um i wanted to try something with
you uh called shoot your shot good where
it's two or three opinions that you
believe that no one else is saying okay
would you like me to go first yeah go
first why not
my first opinion that i believe that i'm
not hearing anyone say is
i believe the san francisco 49ers are
going to win the nfc west
the big competition here is seattle and
the rams i look at what i saw out of
seattle yeah i've had questions about
seattle all off season warranted against
the saints the rams are fantastic but
i'll say you look back at any of the
rams niners games with lesser
quarterbacks and lesser teams kyle
shanahan has hung up points on the rams
every single time the other thing i want
to say is those niners are 3-0
oh we've seen the story before the 3-0
teams that fade off
normally those teams that are 3-0
have an enormous
an advantage in the turnover margin and
it's an inflated 3-0
and i'll just say this the niners are
tied for the league with eight giveaways
yeah
the other two teams that have given the
ball away eight times
cincinnati and miami a combined 0 and 6.
the only team letting up less yards per
game in the air the new england patriots
the niners r the niners defense right
now is top 10 against the run the pass
in sacks and interceptions the
back-to-back road games to start the
season historic in the last like five
years those teams were one in 14 the
niners were able to do it they outgained
the pittsburgh steelers by almost 200
yards and averaged six yards per play
and they turned the ball over five times
none of their receivers are clearly the
number one they have i believe
nine receivers averaging over ten yards
of catch they have three running backs
all of them look good they have an
all-pro tight end in george kittle and a
quarterback who yesterday looked like he
was getting into form
i look at the niners if you take away
the running game they'll attack you in
the past
and now
all those years of drafting defensive
lineman orrick armstead deforest
buttoner nick bosus solomon thomas
finally paying off
every time i turn on the niners game the
opposing quarterback is running for
their lives
jameis winston running for us live andy
dalton running for his life and you
could say oh it's this team i saw andy
dalton take the buffalo bills to almost
overtime in the seattle seahawks i saw
jameis winston knock off the panthers
and hang up like almost 30 plus against
the giants and then they go in there and
play the steelers where okay fight but
they beat the [ __ ] out of the steelers
right
i think the niners are going to win the
nfc west
that's my that's one of my shoot my
shots i'll tell you this i i like john
lynch i like the way he's building the
team i think he's actually i think he's
a really good talent evaluator i think
he's a good dude and i think there was a
time when the the nfc west was a soft
division back when i was playing then it
got really nasty seattle was nasty
defensive defensively the rams were
nasty as well as san fran in
and i think arizona actually was nasty
too so they had a pretty nasty division
out there i think you're right about
that i think that's what they're trying
to have a chance they're trying to build
a situation where
they get out to the quarterback let me
ask you they have a buy this week
which i hate yeah i hate that they're
3-0 and going into a buy
early season buys i feel like you can
throw off everything have you
experienced this well it depends if
you're om-3 you need to buy just to
collect yourself if you're three and oh
you want to keep the ball rolling and
especially early on you're not injured
yet so may your you may be a little
banged up but it's nothing you know that
afterwards if you go three and oh you
got a 13-game stretch after the buy
where you get no breaks and it's hard
that's hard to do so you always want
your by mid-season seven weeks seven
weeks eight week nine somewhere around
there just so that you can get your body
back then maybe you've got another eight
nine games after that just to get that
stretch i i like i like the the uh 49ers
i think they might i don't know if
they're going to win i think i don't
know that they win but i think they'll
compete and i think that's important i
think i'm i'm proud of them though all
right so they have one of the best young
court best play callers in kyle shannon
and i appreciate what he's able to do
all right so shoot your shot give me a
shot hear it anywhere else i don't know
if you're not hearing this anywhere else
i think the stats will probably disagree
with me but i my eyes are telling me
this
that the browns defense
is worse
than miami dolphins wow okay and i want
to tell you i just want to tell you what
the miami dolphins are doing they're
giving up 44 points in the game per game
yeah that's historically the worst
that's the last industry they're giving
up 500 yards per game and that's the
last 229 291 passing yards that's 28th
and 208 rushing yards which i'm going to
tell you right now this is hard to have
stats like this because they look
terrible but i also want you to
understand this
they're not very talented they gave away
one of their best players in maker
fitzpatrick they look like they're
tanking we understand that more
importantly this is the guys that they
played so far baltimore they put up a
bunch of points but baltimore we talk
about them all the time they're actually
gonna be a pretty good team yes new
england they put up 43 points but i also
want to mention they have a hall of fame
quarterback and they had antonio brown
for that game and everybody else went
off they put up they got packed and and
two of those touchdowns were defensive
tests right so it wasn't even off so it
wasn't that way dallas put up 31 points
again you know you're playing one of
these up and rising teams but they held
them to uh ten points in the first half
wasn't wasn't terrible and i want to
look on the other side the browns
what do you mean you can't get out to
the quarterback what do you mean why not
why can't you get to the quarterback why
can't you make things
hard for the opposing team you're really
talking about the rams game on sunday
night yeah what are you doing
why not well this is where your talent
base is supposed to be at what's
interesting about the browns is every
starter of their secondary was hurt
which is wild both safeties all three
corners denzel ward greedy williams wild
but i don't think you're crazy i mean i
look at this browns team right now and
if they're not playing luke falcon week
two and like sam darnold's in there
they're they're a they're a quarterback
injury away from owen three i'm gonna
take this even further uh-oh i think
the broncos defense
is worse than miami
zero sacks zero turnovers you got nick
chubb and and bond miller coming off the
edge you mean to tell me that those guys
can't get a sack i'm gonna see your take
and i'm gonna take your take and i'm
gonna take it take it i actually think
the denver's defense is extremely
underrated really and everybody's
focusing on this one stat well i think
two steps they're focusing on that they
haven't gotten a sack yes and they
haven't got an interception important
and all that stuff and i get it
what i'm saying though is they're the
only team in the last 50 years not to
have a second interception in three
weeks with that they're the sixth best
passing defense in the nfl i watched
that game yesterday with aaron rodgers
they were struggling other than a bomb
to marquez valdez scantling they really
kept that team in check also chicago
goes in there and they could barely get
a first down for the whole game what
happened yeah well chicago has missed
strabisky as their quarterback
what's happening is is when your
quarterback is joe flacco yeah and
you're never [ __ ] giving your defense
rest on the field i think that were
interceptions is a tough thing to
predict right like it you don't average
a certain amount every game
i think the denver defense as a whole is
a good defense it's a sound defense
they're just not getting it right now
and i think teams are proactively
protecting against bradley chubb and von
miller and trying to get the ball out
quickly i think they're trying to avoid
them well yeah that's what you do
against all of the best rushers in the
league however and somehow aaron donald
keeps getting double-digit sacks he has
one sack thus far well yeah but he go he
he started off slow last year too of
course but then he went on a run i'm not
saying that this dimmer team won't go on
a run however
we had a staff for a long time we call
it [ __ ] the player where we believe that
there are certain guys like aaron donald
who every play destroy an office
disruptive they don't get any credit for
it no and so it's really like honoring
those guys you only get credit for that
when you watch the film and you study
you're like okay this is why the
quarterback had exactly that's why it
was a terrible throw i do want to make a
bet with you about the broncos so i have
to see who they play but i'm going to
give you another one
i'll give you a different one
dan quinn will be the first head coach
fired this season oh really and my
reasoning is this
this defense has been abysmal
every single game and what happens when
you're a head coach and before the
season you say i am taking play calling
of this side of the ball over you can't
hide behind anybody you can't fire
anybody else the offense is still
carrying this team they go down early
like 21-3 to indianapolis and now keanu
kneels out with an achilles it's gonna
fall even further as we've seen like it
did last year they're about to host the
titans on 10 days rest
titans defense matches up really well
with atlanta three good corners can
match up with atlanta's offense and that
derek henry running game is going to
have a success against atlanta then they
go to houston where deshawn watson can
put up some numbers i got a feeling
dan quinn might be the first coach gone
in the nfl this season
i kind of agree with you i i also would
put jay gruden right there monday today
will be interesting obviously we're
recording this on monday but we'll see
what happens with them
i think they may be in a race to to
certainly be the first my thing though
is washington is a team that always
waits to make decisions they waiting on
kirk cousins they're waiting out tren
williams that's terrible i just see them
right now with jay gruen we'll wait to
see this yeah atlanta sort of like
we kind of thought we could be a playoff
team and if we end up being one and
three after tennessee
they're gonna be shell-shocked
i got one for you okay
and i don't know that this was a
surprise i don't think anybody's even
talking about it though
two things
dalvin cook okay he's leading the league
in rushing say he's the best running
back in the nfl
when you watch the tape
when you wash the tape i literally got a
tweet from someone that said i can't
wait for adam to continue asking
westbrook who's the best running back in
the nfl this week saying dalvin cook
when you wash the tape every time he
touches the ball he looks like he's
operating at a different speed than
anyone else on the field right he has a
shake to him he makes the first guy miss
he has lateral
and and he's doing things against
defense that you just he has listen when
he came out of school i said you know
what if he could just stay healthy which
he didn't early on he finally got back
healthy and now we're seeing the reason
why he probably should have been a
first-round draft pick we're seeing the
reason why there are a lot of teams
passing them up because obviously some
issues things like that but now he's
making people miss in the hole he can
catch the ball out of the backfield he's
doing everything that the the vikings
need him to do to help carry this
offense so you love saquon i love segway
with saquon on the shelf right now i
still love zeke too okay but look but
this looks different though and in this
way because zeke came back last year and
he looked quicker he looked fast he
looked much more agile side to side he
didn't look as heavy to me that was last
year i think this year he's still going
to be quality running back as he gets up
to speed dolphin looks different speed
wise he looks a little bit different i
think he's going to get more
opportunities they have big two the best
receiving core in the league so arguably
with saquon on the shelf we have to give
the title of best running back in the
nfl to somebody are you giving it to
dalvin right now yes
i i will tell you this though and i
wrote two guys down
and it's kind of scary because i didn't
i didn't see this one coming chris
mccaffrey actually has surprised i told
you bro he surprised me he's phenomenal
i didn't know well you know he put on
some weight in the off season i didn't
know that he would be able to carry the
load in this way and i think that he's
surprised a lot of people obviously
receiving skills are still there to me
that's going to be huge for him as the
season goes on it's just going to be
some games where running game is not
going to be able to go he's going to be
able to help you out in the past game
i think that his ability to run inside
outside that speed and the willingness
there's a lot of backs that can run
inside but they want to bounce it
outside because they want to use their
speed he'll run people he he'll run
people over in the hole and to me
that shows you
from a young back we'll use it i'll use
a greater comparison mal sanders with
the eagles sure he's not seeing it he's
not feeling it right now he's a talented
young kid he just can't see it takes
some time to see it and sometimes when
you're young you think that bouncing it
is the way to go you think that taking a
two-yard game
no get in the seam take your two and
three and sooner or later that two and
three turns into 20 and 30. but you have
to be patient christian he's understood
it he gets it and he's willing to take
the inside and then bounce it later on
and you know this tell me if i'm wrong
here
sometimes you follow that seam in the
first and second quarter that's right
because in the third and fourth is when
you're gonna pop it out that's right but
if you always try to pop it out well
that's your style now now now i'm
defending the pop out well you have to
set things up yeah i used to always tell
andy and andy would always get mad first
quarter why didn't you do this i was
like andy just listen let me do me let
me do what i'm doing i'm setting things
up for the third and fourth quarter this
is the the crunch time when you need me
i'm setting things up for that the best
quarterbacks to that where they focus on
routes no one i'm going to come back to
that route combination later pass
rushers we'll show you a bull rush for
the first three quarters because they
know
money gets made in the fourth quarter
and that's what i'm doing the swim
it's
you cannot look at every play in a
vacuum a play in the first quarter is
not equal to a play in the fourth not
even close and you need to set it up um
the other thing i was going to say is
christian mccaffrey john riggins best
white running back in the history
christian mccaffrey
no no listen john reagan's a hall of
famer he's
he he's i mean john riggins i think
chris mccaffrey is the best white
running back chris mccaffrey is the best
white running back in the league that
does that who is he up against it's him
and rex burkhead that's him that's it
he's listen he's a quality running back
i'm i am really surprised to see it he's
really really good and i was wrong about
him early on in his career i thought he
was going to be limited i thought that
he wouldn't be able to carry the load
yeah you've seen without cam you see
with the young quarterback he's able to
carry the load he's able to help his
team i i am surprised rex burkhead from
i have no clue nebraska really
danny woodhead from shadron state in
nebraska that's what they do there bro
that's what they do in nebraska because
they play seven-man football yeah and
it's just about there's just not a lot
of black people there that's the other
part that's the other part yeah that's
the other part so they can't be yeah you
play seven-man football and all the
players are awesome this is a take i
have it's not it's not a football one
but it's more of i'm asking a question
okay i'm watching giants buccaneers and
they put up a stat for jameis winston as
he's approaching the field for the last
drive and it says
nine fourth quarter nine game-winning
comebacks in his career
dear television producers
please show me
how many game-winning drives he's been
able to attempt total in addition
because when i see that jameis winston
has nine game-winning drives i go that's
pretty impressive
but if i knew it was out of 50 then i'm
not that impressed yeah like drew brees
35 game-winning drives
how many did he fail on that's right
because if you told me 200 fails i'm not
that impressed what would you i want to
know percentages you wanted context you
want to know yes how it might be able to
judge that well
every game you're losing you have the
opportunity to have a game-winning drive
and you only converted nine of them then
that's just not very good so that's
that's my give me some comments that's
my request is this stat that we're
putting up in every game about fourth
quarter game-winning comebacks
give me the percentages do not give me
the total because that if you wrote back
two i'd be like wow he's done it before
i need the percentages do you have any
other uh hot ones for me uh it's okay if
you don't i have one and i don't know
that it's hot because i think a lot of
people are seeing it so so the cleveland
browns are one and two yes i just want
to go through the record and i want to
just to be real about it at baltimore at
san francisco seattle at uh new england
then they have at denver and then
buffalo i'll tell you right now if they
if
if they can win two of those i think
that's good i don't know i don't know
that they win two of those so one thing
that that sharp and i have talked about
a lot is when freddie kitchens and
johnnyman
freddie kitchens and baker mayfield had
success like that's just a 40 and slip
because they look like i'm sorry um had
success last year they won a lot of
heavy sets and they passed out of it and
this year they're playing such a
staggering amount of 11 and you traded
kevin zeitler one of your best offensive
lineman other than joel betonio and
baker is not doing well under pressure
shark gave us the statistic last week
that when baker mayfield heading into
sunday night's game was under pressure
he had a qb rating of 40. and last night
i watched baker with 11 personnel be
under pressure and play really really
poorly
he also right now is one in six against
teams with an over 500 record
but this is the issue
david and joku just went in ir yeah they
have demetrius harris and ricky seals
jones both of them are more wide
receivers than they are tight ends
this is freddy kitchens came out this
morning and said he's going to continue
to call plays
but this could get really ugly really
fast and what everybody was saying this
offseason was the only question i got
about the cleveland browns is freddy
kitchens
so we've already kind of set up the
narrative to where we can blame freddie
kitchens and then i'm watching the game
last night and with the game on the line
on fourth and nine oh wow he calls a
draw play wow
and and my jaw hit the floor shocking
shocking to me if you're calling the
draw play on third and nine maybe
because you know you're gonna go for it
on fourth just to get you some yards
five four four four four that's right
but
is there a chance this could get so out
of line with freddy and the browns have
shown well the browns have not shown
that they'll react quickly because they
did allow hugh jackson to go one in 31
for a long time but
or one in thirty three there's so much
more talent now though they've invested
more in this book that schedule you just
laid out for me
this could get scary well the two things
that we worried about for this football
team early a lot of success
and that team being able to have the
maturity to handle it and having the
coaches say hey not too high not too low
the other part is the low side how many
what happens if you lose three four five
games in a row that little swagger that
you had that was one and six that was
kind of carrying you through camp and
everybody
now what happens how does baker handle
that how does odell beckham jr handle
that what does this team turn to yeah
can i pat myself on the back three times
you need three you need to do it three
times three different things i like to
pack my battery all right go ahead
number one i did say that after sunday
we'd be saying that mahomes and lamar
jacks will be the future of the nfl and
we'd look at the two quarterbacks that
were taken to number one and jared goff
and baker mayfield and go they were
supposed to be the future of the nfl
that's one pat yeah deserve it
okay it was deserved number two i got
into a few arguments this offseason
where people told me that patrick
mahomes would be figured out in the nfl
and i said you're [ __ ] crazy can't
figure out the talent that's right
number two but number three i said in my
season preview that the cleveland browns
of all the town in the world but we were
gonna have fights between baker and
o'dell and and jarvis not because they
didn't do well but because their
offensive line was in shambles and they
wouldn't be able to get it going
that's all i'm going to do when i'm done
i got a question for you got a question
for you i like to celebrate myself we're
talking yeah i see that man that's great
patting you back that's
much appreciated
jackson
baker rosen and donald put him in order
donald who's donald sam darnold oh
darnold darnold what did i say donald
donald yeah sorry sam darnold sam
darnold if i was gonna write them an
order so give me it again lamar jackson
okay baker josh rosen and sam darnold
i am gonna go
um
jackson okay easy one
baker darnold
rosen and the reason i'm putting baker
over darnold is
um i believe baker has a better arm than
darnold i think darnold is better at
escaping and running around but i i
think that um
baker's offensive line right now is is
bad to the point where um it's not
letting us see his full potential uh so
i would i i find them to be very similar
tell me tell me about baker's decision
making because the five interceptions
the three touchdowns obviously i'm
worried about his decision making where
is he throwing the ball does he is he
understanding the defense is he's
throwing the ball to the best possible
outcome he's going to get to if it's an
offensive line issue my big for the best
if i want to fix baker is this you have
todd monken as your offensive
coordinator right who broke a shitload
of records in tampa bay i know that
freddie kitchens wants to keep calling
the plays
you need another mind in that room and i
don't know if you're listening to todd
but you guys got to change it up yeah
because it ain't working it's hard how
would you rank them i i probably would
go lamarr sam darnold obviously i love
that you're all over lamar now well yeah
yeah whatever um
to the dark side darnold has a much
smaller sample size i think but i i
think you would put darnold over baker
in the long term it's a good reaction in
the long term uh let's do who gave their
133 this week who do you want to lead
off with
um i think everybody's jumping over
daniel jones i love that i'm gonna go
with jacoby brissette damn he was my
number one really yeah
i completed his first 16 passes yeah i
think he outplayed matt ryan when you
look at what he's done he goes into la
against the chargers leads a comeback to
send it to overtime with big time throws
he goes to tennessee
with i'm telling you guys if you go back
and watch that tennessee game he is
diving for fourth down conversions he's
making big throws when he's all the
small things and then
and then against atlanta starts off the
game 16 for 16 and then finishes the
game in the second half without t.y
hilton and made some big time throws and
also how about this
he became the third quarterback in colts
franchise history with a 115 plus passer
rating in two of the first three weeks
of the season the other two
peyton manning and johnny unitas andrew
luck never did it
that like that is talk about a [ __ ]
gamer jacoby brissette deserves to get
credit absolutely should i also think
that he's a leader and guys in that
locker room listen in the nfl you follow
the coach things like that and you see
so many personalities but you always
need a leader a guy that you can follow
that's going to be calm in the face of
adversity a guy that's going to say all
right we're not going to get too high
i'm not going to get too low jacoby
brissette is that type of guy he's a guy
that you would follow into the war and
you're saying listen we're going to
follow him if he says go right we're
going right he's that type of leader
obviously you laying out all this stats
you know they scored on the first four
possessions they're putting up numbers
this is what this colts team was trying
to do obviously with andrew luck what's
happening with this colts team and every
game they play
is eventually their offensive line is
too good for the other team that's right
and and the thing about the colts is
every time i talk to quentin nelson
he never wants to accept credit a lot of
people last year want to give him credit
for the offensive line getting better it
is truly a team unit that's right where
the offensive line is giving percent
time brusseta is making the throws and
the wide receivers in the tight ends are
playing better than they ever had on
time the colts are a team that in the
beginning of the year i had the steelers
maybe knock him out of playoffs this is
before all the injuries and all that the
colts right now are going to either win
the afc south or they're going to be a
five or six seat it's too obvious to me
right now the colts will make the
playoffs this year i think they will
obviously you mentioned this early and i
think this is important to say because
we i talked about it last week in one of
my shows that last week carson wentz is
dueling with matt ryan right you want
the bet you want to get the better of
course you're not playing on the field
with him at the same time but i want to
be the best quarterback on the field
same thing this week
jacoby per set you see matt ryan who
some people you know you can make him a
hall of famer one of the better
quarterbacks over the last 15 years
pretty good quarterback i want to outdo
you i want to be better than you and you
talk about a gamer he is a gamer that's
exactly what you wanted that position i
was impressed with him this week
speaking of a gamer i'm going to give
another 133 award to shaquille barrett
we talked about him earlier four sacks
eight on the season but this is what's
beautiful
he already is hit after three games
a clause in his contract that gives him
a 250 000 bonus get that money get that
money and i love when dudes exceed
expectations so early
250 grand and three he that was like
that money oh man that's so good i'm
glad for guys like that in your contract
no no you never had clauses like that no
i want my money up front how about money
here now today because
andy may decide to go throw the ball 150
times i want my money right the amount
of times we've seen it gets a little
dicey and all of a sudden they don't put
you on the field as much oh yeah i got
some questions
hey don't mess with my incentive don't
do that yes not cool all right who else
you wanna give 133 to you know i'm not
surprised by this i i thought i mean i
know this team throws the ball deep but
keenan island continues to just go get
it yes 13 catches 183 yards two
touchdowns i mean listen the texans have
you know their defense is in a little
bit of flux but i think keenan allen
continues to be a beast
all season long he stretches the field
he catches the one-on-one difficult
balls those 50 50 balls we talk about
that you want your receivers just to go
grab he goes and gets those diving 50 50
all the time phillip river says listen
i'm just going to throw it up and you go
figure it out yes keenan allen figures
it out every time big time game this
week and i'm going to give another 133
to another wide receiver josh gordon oh
okay i'm watching the patriots game
yesterday
and he had two catches that were
highlight reels for the season
one on the sideline that led to a
touchdown and one right down the middle
and it's so funny because we've said
this for a long time there's something
about the patriots uniforms that makes
guys look smaller yeah they don't look
as physically impressive but then i
watch josh gordon make those plays and i
go this is the six foot four two it's
like a great pound freak that we've
never seen and if the patriots are gonna
have are gonna continue their run as
everyone expects them to including
myself to be the number one seed and to
go all the way to the super bowl
they need guys that can make plays like
this edelman hurt his chest we'll see
what the deals are the carousel at
running back they do not have a tight
end right now that i believe is far and
away superior it's going to come down to
the josh gordon is going to have to make
a play every game yeah where he takes
the ball away and i thought what he did
against the jets two of those they were
two of the best catches you were going
to see all season big receiver big time
talent he's still his speed to me is a
little bit off and he'll i think he may
get a little bit faster but as he ages
everyone gets slower but you're right
catch radius the ability to say okay i'm
just bigger than you that's what gronk
had gronk was like listen you may be
able to cover me he ran pretty decent
routes but when it comes down to me
catching the ball with you right there
i'm bigger better and stronger than you
historically same thing the job brady
tom brady splits without gronk fell off
a cliff yeah and i firmly believe that
josh gordon is really the gronk
replacement it's not about matt lacoste
or wherever you want to put it tight end
what gronk gave you was the 50 50 ball
when everything's in trouble how did the
patriots beat the rams other than their
phenomenal defense it all came down to
gronk going up at the end of the game
and catching a ball to put them inside
the 10 to set up that red zone offense
that's what josh gordon is josh gordon
is the gronk replacement we just need
him to stay all season long he will good
his focus right now that's what it's all
about and there's something about you
know what happened to a b yeah where i
feel like it reinforces it even more to
judge like i'm looking at josh gordon
i'm looking at darren waller of the
raiders was that your guy you stole him
i got another catch is like 130. i love
what he did he's another guy that has
had a lot of demons that's right that's
right and i think
sometimes it's interesting that both of
them experienced antonio brown on their
team combusting
and there's something about someone
failing miserably in front of you that
that can
i don't sir i don't suffer losses i
suffer lessons but when you can get a
loss and you're not suffering the loss i
think it kind of emboldens them to stay
on the good path and we hope they can
because what they're doing right now is
phenomenal it allows you to refocus it
also allows you to say you know what
i'm doing a great it kind of allows you
to pat yourself in the back just a
little bit you know
at least i'm not there and of course you
never want to say at least i'm not that
guy but the truth is is that you can say
i was there and in the past i would have
made that decision thankfully i'm here
at this place in my life and i'm not
making those things by the way the
decision is what we're talking about is
i'm i'm not equating this to uh what
what antonio brown is accused of saying
of the of the craziness his temperament
yes his his use of social media the
constant challenging of the
non-surrounding the noise that's that's
what we're talking about the the other
stuff is so deplorable that i'd rather
not get into it no of course two last
guys that i'm gonna have then i'll put
these guys together because they're
running backs and they're just getting
it done we talked about both of them
give some credit to your running back
mark ingram love him love him i mean i
think he i've always liked mark ingram
physical presence a guy that can run
with speed and power he can catch the
ball out of the backfield too i love the
fact that they're giving him some
opportunities very efficient yesterday
16 carries 103 yards efficient game
three touchdowns mark ingram runs
at an angle yes where i feel like he
slices through people and the people
that would agree with you the most are
the new orleans saints fans because what
the new orleans fans saints fans are
watching right now is what the vikings
fans realized and what the raiders fans
realized is that yes latavius murray
looks like a hard runner but he cannot
hold a candle to mark ingram
and the saints fans are looking right
now and they're looking longingly at the
ravens and going we miss mark ingram
because he runs at a different strength
than anybody else it also gives you a
attitude yeah he brings an attitude and
when you're on that i'll never forget i
never was this player but every now and
then i would run a guy over and that
gave my offensive line a different feel
way to go west i mean it got dropped
that's how that's how running backs can
do mark ingram could do it you know when
coming out alabama i thought he was a
volume back meaning he couldn't get it
done unless he was getting 25 30 carries
and i think there were times in new
orleans where i kind of felt that way
too the latter part of his time in new
orleans he's spending time with camara
i'm saying you know what mark ingram
probably doesn't need 20 carries a game
just to get going this game 16 carries
he's able to get it going a lot faster
yeah i appreciate that but i love that
core him gus edwards justice hill
they're going to last all season long
they're going to run the football 16
carries 16 carries i mean mark ingram it
seemed like he got 30 carries well he
what i love about though that though is
playoffs mm-hmm he's gonna be ready to
go oh man well here's the other part the
latter part of the season we talk about
all the time defensive guys have to make
a business decision yes
i'm 220 230 whatever i am in the running
back position
how bad do you want to get get me down
on the ground you're you're a defensive
back you're 185 we're 190. how bad do
you want to get me on the ground because
i'm gonna i'm not running around you no
i'm going right there and you're in the
way yeah what decision are you going to
make mark ingram makes teams make that
decision last guy christian mccarthy we
talked about it but i mean he's just
he he's becoming a special guy and i
don't i don't know that people in the
league are still recognizing it i still
think 154 yards 23 carat 24 carries is
impressive he's still catching the ball
out of the backfield i think he can do
even more out of the backfield only he
had three catches for 35 yards he can
help that team 75-yard touchdown run
that there was a defensive effect there
was a defensive pack on his hip yeah and
then out of nowhere he just separated
that's a different gear he has a
different gear coming out of school i
thought he was a speed guy but i'm like
ah i don't know if he had that extra
gear he's proven these over these last
i don't know four or five games and
going back to last year that he has
another gear he can get to he's running
tough inside like we talked about
earlier it's been impressive to watch
him especially without cam there this is
also what i think is unbelievable if you
look back at the 2017 nfl draft with the
fourth pick the jacksonville jaguar
selected leonard fournette
volume back doesn't have the quick
twitch they drafted him over patrick
mahomes and desean watson
and they also drafted him over christian
mccaffrey who went eighth in that draft
and a lot of people looked at the
carolina panthers and said probably a
reach he's probably just a gadget third
down back that's right and instead
christian mccaffery is probably
it's him and dalvin cook right now to
who is the favorite to lead the nfl in
rushing you know what they thought about
christian mccaffrey that he hit his
ceiling while he was in stanford that's
[ __ ] he was the best he was going to
be he would never improve they really
said the same thing to me this is what
he's going to be and he'll be another
yeah this you'll be a third down back
you'll be nothing else obviously he's
getting drafted in the first round so
they thought a little bit higher about
him right third round at the same time
he has the ability to change games
that's what you want in your your
running back core your your play makers
on your team can you change games in a
way that now the defenses have to play
differently when they match up against
speaking of rookies we're now in week
three give me some rookies that have
really impressed you thus far this
season that you go
they were either really under drafted
like because we know daniel jones has
been great if you're 20 years that's
great but like
who is someone that you're going wow
this is a player um
and i'll say this because i saw him
firsthand but i think that he'll
continue uh to to get opportunities
because their team is just bad terry
mclaurin
i i i'm coming look at this westbrook is
loving scary terry now gary terry but
listen it's the deep breath and here's
the other part it's the combination play
the clip with him going two weeks ago
who well nobody knew who he was until
except for you until he's running
scot-free down the middle of the dog on
field and you see the speed similar guy
pick number 56 nicole hardman for the
chief he's on my list as well
he now has two plays where it's like a
direct shot for like 60 yards it's
incredible but he had one play yesterday
where he bobbled it and then broke four
tackles going completely across the
field and got a first down
who is scouting wide receivers for the
chiefs demarcus robinson michael hardman
yeah
and their best guys hurt this is the
other thing i want to say about homes
they're missing their best wide receiver
they missed their starting running back
and they missed their left tackle and
they hung up like 30 plus points like it
was nothing well this is what nothing
this is what special players do it
doesn't matter who's around him no he
still has some talent around he's still
got guys that can run a 4-3 on a bad day
on the wet field kelsey is starting to
get close into this all-time tight end
conversation absolutely
so he has a bunch of weapons around him
but when when you're
that guy yeah you make everyone look
better than they actually are so scary
terry absolutely number one 10 catches
on the season 187 yards this is a good
position for him because that team's
gonna be playing from behind throwing
the football to the bus this season
he'll get a lot of passes pick number
64.
i'm going d.k metcalf he's on my did you
look at my list nope look at my list the
thing that i like about dk metcalf is
everybody that was confident in dk
metcalf was still concerned about dk
metcalf we don't know if he has a full
route tree we don't know if he's
actually going to be that physically
imposing in the nfl i'm watching him at
the end of the first half against the
saints yesterday going up on two guys
and pulling it down
russell wilson and that offense will
bounce back but it's about having guys
just like the patriots because it's a
simpler offense that can win 50 50 balls
right that's what d that's what that's
what we were hoping out of jimmy graham
and didn't get doug baldwin was able to
do it even though he was short in
stature but with lockheed dk metcalf
i've been very impressed with dk matt
cass ability to body up defensive backs
it's been impressive big target big
receiver big strong kid you love to have
bigger and stronger and still have some
speed you're right on the 50 50 balls
he's had at least 60 yards in each of
the first three games it's been
impressive because sometimes when as a
young receiver you don't understand
where is it going to be the opening in
the zones where am i going to find my
fit in there often to be slow with that
we thought his learning was going to be
slow he's come out and played very well
for this football team and i also think
that he was a guy let's not forget i
mean there were people that were saying
i wouldn't draft dk metcalf that's right
he'll never make it in the nfl is what
they were saying because they were
saying uh he's maybe maybe a little
stiff a little hips can't move can't get
in and out of the route well you're
wrong so far you've been wrong uh uh who
else do you got you want more for me i
got i have two more i'm gonna i think
josh jacobs and we know where he is i
mean he's a talented guy i think i'm i
add a guy um alexander matson madison
for dalvin cook
he's getting a bunch of carries he's
been able to carry the ball maybe eight
to ten carries per game but he's
explosive he's averaging you know over
four or five yards of carry he continues
to get it done the vikings want to run
the football he's going to catch it out
of the backfield he's going to get a
bunch of carriers this season especially
when dalvin as the season goes on wears
down just a bit he's going to get some
opportunities i've been impressed with
this play my
number one
guy
that i think other than me cole hardman
who i think has been phenomenal but my
number one rookie
that i go this guy could be a seasoned
church i know you're gonna say who
dibo samuel wrong i do love debo okay
pick number 96
tight end out of ole miss
not talking about dk metcalf not talking
about aj brown dawson knox everybody
right now is loving this stiff arm this
double stiff arm that he had against the
bengals he this is his first week
playing back i'm not even as excited
about that play there was a play in the
first half i think it was a third down
where they ran dawson knox on a jet
sweep and he picked up the first down
tied in tight end really that never
happens with tight ends exactly
my reasoning i said before the year that
i expected the bills to be fighting for
a wild card spot yeah but my issue why i
didn't have them in is i didn't know who
were the big playmakers the 50 50 guys
that's right john brown is a great wide
receiver but we've seen in all those
other teams not a great 50 50 guy cole
beasley they didn't really have that guy
dawson knox
could dawson knox be josh allen's gronk
okay
it's brian dayball comes from the
patriot system was the oc down there in
alabama if you're running jet sweeps and
he's stiff arming the crap out of other
guys
could he be the difference maker for
josh allen when he gets into a pinch
because my question was
can you win if your best athlete is your
quarterback this isn't high school okay
this isn't a le this isn't seven on
seven could dawson knox be the guy
that gives that extra punch for the
buffalo bills when they need it most
they got it on sunday
i'm i'm i'm riding that creek right now
you know what every quarterback loves
more than anything more than protection
of course they want the protection more
than a running game they want a security
blanket a guy that they can throw the
ball to and no if i just get it around
him yes he'll go get it
if i just put it in this area i'm not
concerned with it right that's what josh
allen has in that i mean i mean that's
exactly what it is you you need that
security like it's so many so
we talk about mahones and kelsey that's
a security blanket my other question is
if you had aj brown dk metcalf and this
kid on the same college team
the they'll be [ __ ] hard to lose they
did yeah it's like when i see that
picture of the georgia bulldogs and it's
sony michelle todd gurley and nick chubb
yeah and you went to the belk bowl yeah
yeah well it's only one ball you can't
they all play the same position you
can't i don't care all right so
you know what we saved it for the show
it's the end of the show we're about an
hour and 20 in so let's wrap up but i
only i only want to give them a little
bit of time they do not deserve a lot of
our time okay
your eagles confidence meter we save
them for the end because that's where
they deserve yeah you were what last i
was 4.5 last week and i was 5.1 yeah
um i i i cannot give him a negative
number
but i'm at 0.5
i don't want to give them a negative
number because i think you know you
they're dealing with a bunch of injuries
they're dealing with situations where
your carson is throwing the ball it's a
bunch of guys that he doesn't even know
uh you know young guys are saying i'll
take a white side i mean can't cast the
ball guys are making drops so i'm not
going to give them
a negative number but 0.5 that's it i'm
just disappointed i'm not seeing any
creativity with the offensive play calls
i'm not seeing a great push and blocking
from the offensive line defensively i'm
i'm afraid that no one in that secondary
can cover
i'm defensively my fletcher cox my
defensive player of the year who i think
could be
he's still injured
and he's and he lost his two running
mates he's elite jackson he lost again
they're not getting the pressure off the
edges zero sacks every time they every
time they blitz they get beat deep they
were the only home team at one o'clock
on sunday to be losing at halftime
you're losing at halftime to the detroit
lions oh sneakily are they're pretty
good they're not pretty good they're
decent you shouldn't be losing to them
at home especially if you have a
franchise guy we talk about the
difference makers at quarterback
position if carson wins is that
difference maker that everyone is
telling me about and i'm not he didn't
have a bag seven drops he had seven
trucks
he didn't have he did not have a
terrible game however
i want i want him to make a difference i
want him to figure out a way to win it
that's what i want at the end of the day
i feel like if i put patrick holmes in
the game he has two minutes left and he
has the ball he'll just figure it out
i want to feel that way about carson
wentz and again it's not all his fault
anything else you want to get off your
chest about this team because i know
you're probably upset about it no that's
it i'm just
again they don't deserve a lot of our
time before i give my confidence i want
to tell you how i believe
the next um
one two three four five six weeks are
going to go before the buy that's a
tough stretch okay
they play green bay on thursday night i
think it's a loss they go to one and
three i agree they play the jets sam
darnold might be back that week that's a
win it's a win it's two and three i
think they then lose at minnesota they
lose at dallas i think they lose at
buffalo and i think that
they beat chicago which means they go
into the buy at three and six
okay
my confidence meter last week i was a
5.1 for the philadelphia eagles right is
a 6.9
that makes no sense i'm going to start
by saying that makes no sense and that's
why it makes so much sense because what
they're going to do after that
is exactly what they do every year
you've told me now for three straight
weeks the eagles like to be an underdog
yeah we've said constantly that the
eagles like to play from behind
that's what they're about to do because
after the buy they're going to beat the
patriots at home they're going to beat
the seahawks they're going to go to
miami and win and now we're six and six
they're gonna rattle off eight straight
wins and go ten and six and you know why
i'm so confident nope because of what
happened at the end of that game
they were down and getting obliterated
and then the defense turned it on and
malcolm jenkins blocked a field goal
yeah proof
that the magic still exists that's a
magic [ __ ] that doesn't happen a lot
and it went down there and they had some
drops and carson once wasn't able to get
it done yeah i believe that the eagles
are setting up again the problem is this
year if you finish 10 and 6 and let's
say maybe they lose that game of the
patriots so they lose that game of the
bears and they finish nine and seven
that's not getting you the playoffs this
year no because when you look around the
nfc
seattle is two and one the rams are
three-and-oh the niners are three-and-oh
the saints are two-in-one minnesota's
two and one detroit's 201 green bay is
3-0 and dallas is three-and-oh
it's the nfc is too loaded this year but
i believe that we're gonna see the
eagles go about three and six and then
have a huge run but
this is what the eagles did last year
they were four and six i think it in the
beginning of the year and they kept
losing games the eagles played better
from behind and to have that many drops
to have those kind of turnovers miles
sanders head turns backwards i'm going
six nine because i'm feeling sexual i'll
tell you this
nice the concern is if you know i'm
being crazy if you go to a point where
you lose four or five in a row
those injuries start to pile up and then
guys start to say well is it worth me
coming back second oldest roster in the
nfl that concerns me yeah that concerns
me a bunch of injuries already two three
weeks into the the season
it's hard for guys to come back and stay
healthy that's a big concern yeah
i i candidly really don't have a lot of
confidence in this team uh at the same
point
they play better when their backs
against the wall that's true and doug
peterson calls a better game absolutely
he has to get into the groove too i i
i'm baffled by this football team you
talk about a bunch of talent super bowl
aspirations
we have not we've seen a team come out
that plays with no excitement
i did them that's a problem i did the
math last night
heading into halftime the eagles are
going in minus 27 on the season thus far
that is the fourth worst in the nfl tied
with arizona the only people that are
worse heading into halftime
miami yep
the giants
and atlanta
slow starts slow starts and that hasn't
gotten better all season long really
you talk about a team that has in the
prior to this game
uh scoring in the first quarter 12 out
of the last 18 games they have not
scored in the first quarter
those are slow starts yeah what happens
when the team comes back at them the the
lions didn't give up they kept on coming
back but early on early on guess i'd say
this came against green bay on thursday
uh i remember playing green bay on a
thursday like three or four years ago
and they lost by about like 28. yeah
it's ugly i could see the same thing
happening i could see it happening yeah
that would actually be my prediction
green bay's defense looks good i tell
you what that that secondary for the
eagles has to figure it out in a short
period of time yeah because you know the
aaron rodgers right so let's let's get
out of here uh you're going to give me a
dollar because you lost i'll find the
video and you'll pay me yeah very
excited for that all right brian
westbrook you're the [ __ ] man nick
ingber uh you guys are the [ __ ] movie
trailers we're [ __ ] grading bro i
love you uh for oh the fans are asking
i'm gonna go for brian westbrook and
then you need to kind of have a
catchphrase yeah so do you want to try
one out and then we'll just like
workshop it all right so so because i go
i'm the lefkoe man um so
for brian westbrook i kind of feel like
you probably should tell me before we
get to this point like hey that was a
long one i don't know if i should you
should have told me before it gets to
this point oh but what about oh i got
one go ahead okay okay okay
for brian westbrook the rocket man
did you like that no you hate that one
okay i'll work on it i got to see i got
some time you didn't just come up with
this ellie oh this is crazy
by yourself we'll holler at you guys
later man peace
[Music]